we're floating above the biggest blue
hole in the Americas
stretches at least 274 meters beneath
the seabed here just off the coast of
Mexico's Yucatan Peninsula
it was discovered by Jesus port's dad
my father was a diver and he went after
a regrouper he was chasing it and he
went into the hole and that's when he
saw it for the first time
but that was 20 years ago after that the
hole was forgotten just one of many in
this Bay until Jesus began working with
expert Juan Carlos Al serica and
mentioned it
they went back and measured it and were
astonished by its depth
I felt like a pirate in the Caribbean
when they discovered a treasure because
it was something new
unlike a treasure as well we knew we had
to keep it secret until we could check
it
now they can talk they verified it as
the second deepest Blue Hole in the
world and named it Tam ha deep water in
Mayan the language here
Tom ha was formed by changing sea levels
provoked by ebbing and flowing glaciers
thousands of years ago but it's more
than just an erosion feature says Juan
Carlos it's a window into another time
the conditions in our oceans millions of
years ago were similar to the whole now
not a lot of oxygen in the water limited
light large amounts of pressure so it's
a chance to see all these processes
close off in this unique space
and it's not just the past that Tam ha
could open the door to this Blue Hole
could even tell us what life is like on
other planets without the light and the
oxygen that we have on Earth and even
perhaps how we and other species might
survive there
back at the lab Juan Carlos shows us
what Tam ha looks like below
Cassandra in the boat sends pulses of
sound down and each pulse of sound gives
us the depth of each point and when we
put together the cloud of all those
points we get the shape of the hole
until now all that scientists have found
inside it are carpet of bacteria algae
and sea snot but they hope to find new
species in due course after waiting for
thousands of years Tam ha is still
giving up its Mysteries slowly
John Holman Al Jazeera catalitas Mexico
foreign